[Music]
every day is Valentine's Day for you
that's the same things yeah I mean have
you seen her
yeah yeah have you seen me tell me I'm
not the luckiest guy give us a little
hint about what you guys have planned on
Valentine's Day at least she got me a
box of those sweethearts
candy ah and wrote to Blake love Alicia
and and I'm gonna scratch that out and
give that to to Gwen and outside of that
I don't I don't know yeah we're betting
Blake will do a lot more than that for
Gwen but it seems like their
relationship may be making Adam Levine a
little jealous his I want my bromance
back fever even caused him to crash our
interview from across the room
[Music]
hey you may know where Waldo is anybody
anybody seen Waldo there is okay found
him found Waldo all of us mess with
Blake pretty much except she doesn't
really this looks nice your boyfriend
and I don't so I'm not saying this with
any bitterness or any resentment at all
cuz I don't have any but I pretty much
have no allies Mickey
what are you wrong with that guy he is
very sensitive all bets are off when the
voice returns later this month
judges Adam Blake Gwen and Alicia Keys
are all in it to win it but Blake and
Gwen might have an unfair advantage
because behind the scenes they take
their work home with them do you and him
team up on an alliance at all do you
think they do yes yeah I don't go little
if I think a little bit I have some bro
I mean we we do talk about it like on
off days like we'll be driving home and
like I'm like do you think I should put
these two people against each other
whenever we like oh yeah yeah yeah and
all of a sudden she's like wait a minute
I'm talking to you about I don't believe
you I feel like you're trying to just
leave me right now is there consequences
what happens when you go home after
something like that happens well she's
sleeping on the couch that's what
happens I'm telling you right now I'm
sure she will be in the doghouse stop
the plate how about this it has been a
big week for voice winter cassadee Pope
she became the first artist from the
show to be nominated for a Grammy and
now she is engaged Pope and fiancé Ryan
Dawson announced the news on social
media